16 candles obviously
was that that's the movie that really
took took things off for you i mean that
was it did man it did you know because
so i can't imagine what it's like to be
15 16 years old and you're just become a
star i mean how do you keep you couldn't
straight i couldn't either man it was a
trip it was it's like everything you do
at that point yeah so i read somewhere
like you were the fourth most uh they
said the fourth best teen actor of all
time you were ranked on this list of 200
teenagers and they said you were number
four i don't know how you weren't number
one what was that like a vh1 contest
what was it i don't know what it was wow
but i'm telling you it seems like
everything you touched turned to gold it
was mostly hughes honest to god michael
he was great you know he had these
parties set up the scripts were great
there were always a nice sort of equal
distribution of fun stuff for us to do
and just the way he worked man he gave
us all those great opportunities and
like i said he was very cool with like
collaborating
trying stuff he was always kind of
conspiring with the actors to make it
funnier
and uh you know in a similar way david
gordon green same thing man very natural
talented writer
great director
not sticklers not sticklers great
perfect word you know really open to the
process and fluid and let things happen
which is cool and i think when when
directors are like that as you know
you're gonna you're gonna go that much
further for the director man you're
gonna do you know yeah give it your all
so that's the environment that he
created michael that's why it was great
have you had experiences where you you
don't get that freedom man or you just
like no say it by the way well you know
how it is yeah without naming names you
know you do movies or even tv shows man
and you don't necessarily always get
that vibe from directors and i've worked
with a lot of great directors and some
okay you know some great tv directors
you know um
and you know you're always learning but
some of them are more
you know subdued than others or they
might work from the monitor you know how
to just get a variance of different
things with different people well they
say like i've read you i'm sure you've
heard the story a million times but that
john was really upset when you didn't
take ferris bueller and you didn't take
uh
what's the other one uh pretty pink yeah
and he was really upset and you you the
friendship was sort of severed for a
while is that true you know what
happened mike when i was promoting
hollywood kills uh halloween kills in
new york a couple weeks back i had a
nice conversation with a guy at a
magazine and then this this headline hit
and i'll tell you what happened
for years i kind of opted not to tell
the story but the truth is i he did
write those two projects for me he
wanted me to do them
at the time he was going to have howie
deutsche was a great guy i know howie um
i worked with his wife leah thompson he
was going to direct pretty pink and he
wanted me to star in ferris bueller and
i was actually booked and busy on some
other projects so it just didn't work
out
and i think that kind of broke john
hughes's heart it broke mine too because
i really wanted to continue that
relationship yeah so that's how it
happened man you know and then years
later the last time i talked to him um
he called me with john candy on the
phone
it was incredible man and we hung out
like this for a couple hours and just
you know shot the [ __ ]
and he talked about the potential for
like a breakfast club sequel and all
these things were in his eyes you know
in his
in his thinking at that time um
but he was just the greatest man i love
him we were always laughing he'd take us
to blues bars we'd go to record stores
you know we'd go and hang out at his
house i mean what he did for me he did
for so many you know so many so it's not
like just you know right right you know
the deal there's so many great actors
and actresses and he was just putting us
on the map and giving us opportunity man
did he throw [ __ ] at you like
hey mike tr try try this uh add this
line right here do this
do your own take but be just go off on
this yeah no no we would talk it out
between takes i would run to the
sidelines and get you know his input and
oh no dude we were always doing that man
what's a scene that you remember or
scenes that just elevated so that you
were like when you first started filming
it it was like okay this is kind of
funny yeah but it just became something
way funny okay perfect example this is
the true story i'm guessing the car
scene well let's go back to say yo
there's one of them i got one for that
too so watch this we're shooting 16
candles i'm 15 years old i look 12 like
a bobble head
and
i remember we're casting we're in
chicago and we're doing the casting
rounds for the guys who are going to
play my buddy
my two buddies so hughes turns to me i
swear to you i'm 15 years old he goes
well to your buddies i'm going to let
you cast them i was like what what so i
cast cue sack i don't even know if
cusack knows this call me john you cast
john i swear to you because john hughes
said so i was like i can't i couldn't
believe it either and then this other
guy darren who played the other sidekick
who was hilarious
so back to the scene work i mean that
scene at the high school dance for
example just coming up with [ __ ] like
smacking them in the face you know
you turning around when you're like all
of that [ __ ] all of that all that shit's
all you yeah well no because he cut me
loose because he we would come up we
would talk about it and then he would go
go surprise him and do that this time
you know or goofy [ __ ]